bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france à l'occasion de la
prière de l'angélus dimanche le pape
françois évoqué la crise migratoire il
demande à la communauté internationale
de trouver une solution à cette
situation
est ce que c'est une prise de parole qui
pourrait pousser la communauté
internationale à agir vite selon vous
écoutez c'est pas la première fois que
le pape prend une position comme
celle-là
je dirais que toutes les positions
toutes les prises de parole politiques
sont nécessaires pour bien faire
comprendre que la situation des
personnes en exil en libye
est extrêmement difficile elle est
parfois atroces et qu'elle nécessite une
solution collective rapide destinée
notamment à évacuer une partie de ces
gens qui sont aujourd'hui détenus dans
des centres de détention formelle ou
détenues dans des entrepôts au sein
desquelles ils sont torturés et racketté
rançonner ou encore dans des bidonvilles
où il sert de 2,2 de main d'oeuvre à des
as des as des as des milices donc on a
un souci avec le plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes d'origines très
diverses à la fois d'afrique
subsaharienne deux camps de l'afrique
parfois du moyen-orient et d'extrême
orient qui sont venus pour certains
chercher du travail en libye pour
d'autres trouver une façon de fuir leur
pays d'origine et qui sont bloqués dans
ce pays soumis à des violences
absolument inouïe et pour lesquels
finalement très peu de choses sont
faites par les pays occidentaux en
particulier alors dans ce contexte là
effectivement la prise de parole du pape
est importante et on espère que à
l'instar d'autres elle servira de déclic
afin que des mesures soient prises or
dit que les pays occidentaux se
préoccupent garad
là des conditions
de
d'accueil des migrants en libye pour
quelles raisons
côté c'est plus que ne pas s'en
préoccuper c'est à dire que l'union
européenne
et dans un mécanisme de cogestion avec
la libye de sa frontière de sa frontière
sud cogestion qui passe notamment par le
financement et la formation de gardes
côtes libyens qui intercepte et ramène
en libye les personnes exilées qui
souhaitent fuir le pays donc l'union
européenne contribue très clairement à
cette situation d'ailleurs
le haut commissariat aux droits de
l'homme des nations-unies n'a pas dit
autre chose indiquant que ces
refoulements pouvaient être qualifiés de
crimes contre l'humanité donc on a
aujourd'hui un vrai problème politique
éthique morale du l'union européenne
dans sa gestion de sa frontière sud
comme c'est le cas également de sa
frontière est comme on vient de le voir
en parlant de la situation entre la
pologne et la biélorussie
par exemple justement certains pays tu
es évoque la construction on a parlé
donc de barrières anti néo grand votre
réaction
tout ça est à la fois malheureux et très
peu surprenant on est dans un monde où
les murs se sont multipliés on sait
d'expérience que ces murs non je dirais
une efficacité que provisoire et
relative que les trajets les routes
migratoires évolue en fonction de ses
murs c'est une des raisons pour laquelle
aujourd'hui
vous en parliez également dans votre
reportage la route entre l'afrique de
l'ouest en particulier sahara occidental
et la mauritanie vers les canaries
connaît un regain de fréquentation
depuis ces dernières années précisément
parce que la route de la méditerranée
centrale vers l'italie est rendue
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus difficile
donc ces routes évoluent au gré des
politiques migratoires empêchant une
mobilité qui s'inscrit bien dans un
contexte structurel est ce qu indique
toutes ces images qu'on a vu depuis
depuis tout à l'heure c'est que l'union
européenne comme un site comme les pays
du monde et y compris les pays d'origine
et les pays transit de ces personnes
migrantes refuse de considérer la
question migratoire comme une donnée
avec laquelle il faut je dirais
faire qu'il faut gérer plutôt que de
chercher à l'empêcher au prix de
souffrances humaines extrêmement
importante comme on le voit en libye ou
d'une mortalité élevée comme on vient de
le voir de nouveau aux canaries ou comme
c'est le cas aussi régulièrement en
méditerranée centrale puisqu'on est à
près de 2000 morts il me semble
cette année entre la libye et l'italie
donc c'est une c'est une crise un toute
façon qui ne date pas d'hier en tant qu
alger est ce que vous observez du coup
un nombre croissant de migrants toujours
un peu plus qui risquent leur vie pour
atteindre les côtes européennes ces
dernières sont mal
écouté le le je dirais que la
fréquentation de la mer méditerranée
varie régulièrement en fonction de la
météo d'événements politiques
on est en ce moment plutôt dans un dans
un pic de fréquentation on a à bord du
bateau msf léger au bahreïn sont pas
loin de
300 personnes aujourd'hui qui ont été
secourues à l'occasion d'opérations
diverses
on a un bateau qui vient de débarquer en
sicile le site watch débarquant pas loin
de 400 400 personnes
par ailleurs on a assisté il ya quelques
jours de cela à l'arrestation de cinq
mille personnes
dans les faubourgs bidonville de libye
qui ont été ramenés dans les centres de
détention une partie de ces gens là
avaient déjà fait la traversée avait
déjà intercepté donc on à dire eh oui
une fréquentation en tout cas régulière
qui est malgré tout beaucoup moindre que
ce qu'elle qu'elle a été par le passé
notamment dans les années 2000 14 15 et
16 du fait de l'armement
par l'union européenne en particulier
des garde côtes libyens qui empêche les
passages de personnes migrantes merci
beaucoup à vous michaël neuman je
rappelle que vous êtes directeur
d'études à la fondation médecins sans
frontières